foreign
[Music]
how did you come to make this
documentary together
um the the the origin of everything is
um my relationship with the family
Ferragamo and the same relationship the
relationship with Francesco Mansi was
here our producer with the family
um we we knew about Salvatore and
um
and I knew about the book and and
Francesco put me under the attention of
the book again
and
um in the book Shoemaker of dreams that
he wrote
and that he almost got written by a
couple of Hollywood writers at the Times
um hitchcockian writers yes yes there
was a samaj in it even if it was a
thought of self geography it was
fascinating and so that's how we started
um so Dana you had done a book pretty is
this the first documentary that you had
written
yes I've actually
um written a couple books but my first
book Deluxe there's a whole section on
Ferragamo it's called Deluxe High luxury
lawsuits luster but it's about I gave a
large portion of a chapter to the story
of Salvatore and read this book that I
knew very well and I had visited the
museum and really got to know the house
and Luca knew the book and so he called
me and said
do you want to do this I said well yeah
definitely
um I'm wondering for the both of you
what it is that attracts you to Fashion
subjects
I don't think that Ferragamo is strictly
related to fashion honestly I don't
think he would certainly not in the
sense of the industry as it is now for
sure but also if you think of his work
and his Creations back when he was doing
them and forging
uh his art I don't think he was really
much into that
I think it was more about like invention
prototyping
and like
trying to find a way through an
Enterprise that spoke to his hubris as
as an artist as a Creator I would say I
think Ferragamo became a fashion house
when he died and then his family took
the reins of on the business the wife
the wife the wonderful wife Wanda and
fermenta but up until then I think it
was more about like a sort of almost an
artist who say yeah he was he loved
craftsmanship but he was also a driven
entrepreneur
and between the two of these he loved
working with his hands but he also
wanted to get out of the small village
and he had dreams of becoming a very
successful Bourgeois businessman and he
really that's what what drove him more
than anything I think is that he just
was a an entrepreneurial part at such a
young age too I was so fascinated to
hear that he had gone to Naples at 12
years old to study how to make shoes and
then the United States at 16. is when he
first came over
it's crazy it's so driven from like a
such a young age I think I think the
boundaries of the world has always been
very small for him I think he needed to
be really exploring a lot
um so you talk about two incidents in
his life in this that probably not a lot
of people knew about
um one was the terrible car accident
that killed one of his brothers
and the other was the bankruptcy of his
first company
uh either one of those things could have
been devastating enough to make him you
know totally stop and and rethink what
he was doing do you have an impression
what it was that kept him
on the path towards this goal that he
had
I think it was exactly that drive that
he just had this he had this hunger in
him and he wanted to keep going and he
also had this obsession with
um with Anatomy without with the foot
and trying to figure out how to
make the perfect shoe and make people be
able to walk comfortably men and women
and I think that it became such an
obsession that he was able to Channel
all the distress of the accident and
everything else into that work it was
interesting when we did the research for
the documentary
being a newspaper person I I went and
dug through newspaper archives and I
actually found the original news
clipping reporting the the accident in
the Ventura newspaper from the 20s I
couldn't believe that we dug it up but
we found it which was really interesting
from that you know it was such an
important big accident that it made the
newspaper right I think for Ferragamo
was really very much about a mission
that he was really actually acted by
I think that that it's you know like I
think the genius was really making him
be
and I don't I think that even the
difficulties were in a way
for him things that were helping him
to to there more to do more to be more
I think you know when you think about
him here in Hollywood you know
making the shoes for all the stars and
and probably making a really good living
it's hard to imagine what would take him
back you know to start kind of start all
over again but
he wasn't getting any credit
he wasn't Ferragamo then you know you
have to sort of like go back and see
like yes he was hanging out with all
these famous people who loved his shoes
but he wasn't Ferragamo it wasn't a
brand yet so and yet when he came in
Hollywood from Santa Barbara to here
then he opened his shop here which was
one of the addresses right I think it's
now a tattoo parlor
is it I was wondering what was there uh
was said Hollywood Las Palmas was right
on the corner my sister used to live on
Las Palmas
exactly where Rick Owens started yep
um the crossroads of the world is that
near that intersection no
oh that's Cherokee okay
um everything's like I'm trying to have
a map of Hollywood in my mind but I just
can't picture exactly where it was
um so
um
did you expect to get a laugh on the
line I love feet when you when you uh
the narration starts I love feet I
laughed to myself when I saw it at home
and then I noticed here when I watched
it with them there was a laugh again
I'm glad it worked
I don't know I love it
um your narration is done by Michael
stilbarg who was in call me by your name
um why did you feel who I thought was so
great for this
um why did you feel Michael would be a
great choice to do that well all the
narration is coming from is is basically
coming from the book and from his voice
he's a voice the voice of Ferragamo uh
you know like we hear the voice of
Ferragamo in the movie right and it was
a very warm voice very kind of like a
voice that that kind of way in a way
like
story tells you what what he wants you
to listen to
but at the same time you can feel that
there is in this voice really like a
sort of strong passion
and I thought about Michael first of all
because I love Michael and he's such a
great actor and I all want to work with
him all the time but also I felt like he
could Encompass this kindness in a
beautiful way
um
yeah and the passion and the passion and
then Michael is also playing
uh bones and all as well so it's it's
someone I want to be with a lot
um
yeah I thought that there was the voice
of narration was um was fantastic and
also his the audio of Salvatore was
wonderful where did you find this audio
was it in an archive somewhere well the
the museum Ferragamo and the foundation
Ferragamo basically has every single
every single thing you can think about
Ferragamo everything they have
everything
so it was beautiful to dig out things
it was fun to dive into it and and I
mean yeah we had the book but then to
know that there were work that the book
was based on recordings and that the
recordings were there too was just
fantastic
yeah he speaks so eloquently about his
work uh I just love listening to him
talk about it and and the way that he
envisioned shoemaking and
um his curiosity comes out so much you
know like I wanted to know this about
the anatomy and I wanted to know that
and so he just
that was amazing to me being he was in
Santa Barbara and he was just like I
need to know more about Anatomy I'm
enrolling at USC it just seems so like
whatever you wanted to do he just did
and
it's just so determined and so
um I always got the sense he was also
always in a good mood right yeah did we
ever come across anything where he was
cranky or throwing a tantrum or anything
no no no no no he did seem very he was a
jolly he's a very like grounded person
for being a dreamer he's a very grounded
person this image of like everybody
going over to his house for spaghetti
yeah I I was like gosh I also think that
Salvatore was
a great marketing person you know like
he learned quite soon that he had to
sell the idea of Italy that yeah he
thought it was really working
he wasn't really interested in Italy per
se right you talking about his legacy of
Florence which is an invention
it it taught like where where I should
put my brand in order to make it sound
Italian invented Florence for his
company and his son and his son said
that too he is to invent made in Italy
which which Ferragamo did
yeah it's really interesting
um it's very like forward thinking too I
think
um
so did you shoot some of these scenes at
the portanone silent film festival yeah
no sorry we did at the bologna Chile
maritrovato sorry oh bologna okay
bologna not important I've always wanted
to go to that we're all these great
Scholars there yeah which was fantastic
some of those are some of which I
recognized and I was like Dave Iceberg
yeah
we shall we interviewed him in
California
yeah it's great to hear them like
contextualize the time period you know
that this was happening in the United
States and what was happening the birth
of the film industry and how he was a
part of the birth of of the glamor of
the film industry it's amazing
absolutely what kind of kind of was one
of the agent of
understanding what star system meant
and how to play with the image of of a
star
and you know nobody was going to give a
good performance if they were
uncomfortable in their shoes right
I mean it just makes sense
it just made sense he was a really
important person in the movie industry
you had to have comfortable shoes
um do you find it interesting that he
left the USA in 1927 which is you know
Mark's
the film industry at the end of the
silent era and right before the crash
too yeah
it's interesting yeah probably he might
have felt that something was changing
and so like that he might have felt that
he had to do something for himself
I I do not believe it was just longing
for home because at that stage what was
home for him I think it really must have
really felt that there was a great shift
and that he wanted to play in the new
regime from a different perspective yeah
yeah a lot of people have written about
what that time must have been like in
the in the film industry and pretty much
everybody imagines it as a huge upheaval
for everybody on all levels
um no matter what you did in the
industry
um when that first silent film came out
the The Jazz Singer
um
he says in this
fashion with Comfort that's what I gave
when he said what is he he was asked
what is he famous for
what did you think about does that
encapsulate
what his contribution is for you not for
me no I kind of not believe that fashion
should be comfortable actually
I think I think it's a I think it's like
a mistake but
um
yeah because it's all about the
invention of self through the way in
which you present yourself right
um I think I think certainly he was a
wonderful creator of images and craft
that's what I loved him the most for
so do you think for the two of you um
are more documentaries in your future
for me oh yeah I hope so I kept making
documentaries all my life I'm now
working on something since a few years
now that I haven't not been able to
conclude but a documentary yeah
I did many many one what is it that's
different about documentary and
narrative filmmaking that you like
do you get to exercise some different
muscles a lot in in narrative filmmaking
I love performance if performance can
allow me to
record Behavior
and try to go away from drama as much as
I can
and in documentary there is a refreshing
lack of drama
yeah and I like to to to meet people
it's good to meet people that you don't
know and things that you don't know
and it's it was nice for me because I've
always been a journalist a writer
writing books and it's a
and there is the bit where you go out
you report you meet people
but then there's the part I call going
in the cave where you're just alone at
your computer writing and what was nice
about this process was working with
people and you know working on narrative
and Gathering quotes with like doing it
with people as opposed to just being by
myself or having my notebook and taking
notes and then going back and doing it
by myself so
it was and also watching and adding
another dimension to the work was really
great
do in doing writing
um research process like this projects
like this can be so lonely but when you
find that bit of information that you've
been looking for or you find something
that you didn't know that you were
looking for and found something that
contextualizes things because doing
um
movies and books on silent film subjects
is like a treasure hunt there's so much
that hasn't been rediscovered that it's
just buried treasure it's just it's it's
such a a ripe field for for
documentaries and books and everything
because there's and when you say when
you found that that news article there's
so much buried treasure in archives
um that I find it like totally amazing
and over there was a moment that at the
end there where she talks about how he's
good bread but he's hard bred I was
gonna ask about that and that was
something where you know we had so much
material in the archives I don't even
think the ferragamos knew everything
they had and we poured through I read
ever all the catalogs and all the books
and all the interviews and transcribed
this and had that and and then at the
very end I was going through this huge
stack of papers and I came across that
paragraph and I was like oh that's
really lovely
that's a little gem that was buried in
there tell us what you think that meant
he was oh he was a good bread he's a
hard bread but he's still a good bread
yeah yeah I'm sure he was he was not
easy to be with because he was so driven
and she had six kids and had to run a
perfect house it was and he was away all
the time though he came home for lunch
every day
which probably had to be his you know
particular perfect as the shoes he was
making you know like what did you think
about the the good bread but hard bread
line
well I think that very come from the
south you know
it's typical kind of metaphor from
people from the South
um from the south of Italy yeah why is
that it's like about like making the
metaphor of like something essential
that it's about life but at the same
time can tell you what the hardship of
life you know like but and with like
hard bread you might not chew it but if
you soak it then you can make a soup out
of it you know like it's about being
able to be used in many ways and really
sustaining you for long
I think it's a great metaphor
and beautiful
yeah it was terrific
well thank you so much to the two of you
for coming and talking
[Music]